[موسيقى]
إنها ساعة الغداء في دبي
، ويقوم الطهاة في كيتوبي بإعداد
الطعام لـ 40 مطعمًا مختلفًا في
وقت واحد ، إنه طلب طويل جدًا
بفضل مساحة تجارية عالية التقنية
تُعرف باسم المطبخ السحابي ، فكر في الأمر
على أنه مطبخ يسمح
للعلامات التجارية  توسيع نطاق أعضاء فريقنا هم في
الواقع من
يطبخون الطعام نيابة عن العلامات التجارية في
منطق الموارد المشتركة
، الفكرة الكبيرة التالية لصناعة المطاعم
هي الاستعانة بمصادر خارجية لإنتاج الطعام
للمطابخ السحابية مثل يوتوبيا الرئيس
التنفيذي محمد بلوط الذي أطلق كيتوبي في
دبي في 2018
لدمج ورقمنة المطعم
تستخدم سلاسل التوريد
العلامات التجارية العالمية مثل بابا
جونز
وإيشيبان مطابخ لتوفير المال على
مطاعمهم المادية وتوصيل
العملاء بشكل أسرع ، كل ذلك يبدأ
بطلب عبر الإنترنت يذهب الطلب مباشرة
إلى مطبخنا ،
نقوم بطهي الطعام الذي ندفعه للعلامة التجارية
مقابل رسوم الملكية مقابل الحق  لاستخدام علامتنا
التجارية ، تأتي خدمات المجمّع و 3pl
وتلتقط الطلب بمجرد أن
يتم
تجهيزه بـ in-  يمكن للمطابخ السحابية من مجموعة أدوات المطبخ الذكية التي تم بناؤها في المنزل
الطهي بفعالية للعديد من العلامات
التجارية ومعالجة ما يصل إلى ثلاثة آلاف طلب
يوميًا ، والغرض من البرنامج هو حل
ثلاثة أشياء رئيسية من منظور التشغيل ،
جودة توافر الطعام
وسرعة التسليم  هذا
الطعام بفضل اتفاقيات الترخيص مع
حوالي 200 سلسلة مطاعم ،
تستخدم kitopi نفس الوصفات
والمكونات لتلبية
توقعات العملاء التي يريدون كبد الطعام
سريعًا
الذي يريدونه بجودة ممتازة ،
ومن المتوقع دائمًا أن ينمو هذا السوق إلى 71.4
مليار دولار على مستوى العالم.
2027 وفقًا لأبحاث السوق المتحالفة ، فإن
بعض العلامات التجارية مثل نيويورك بوندي سوشي
تقوم أيضًا بالاستعانة بمصادر خارجية لشركة kitopi للتوسع
في المنطقة
بتكاليف أقل ، وهي خطوة تقود
نمو kitopi في الشرق الأوسط ،
فأنت علامة تجارية في نيويورك تريد
التوسع فيها إلى دبي.  سنقوم بترخيص علامتك
التجارية إلينا
في غضون أسبوعين ،
وستعيش بتقنيتها الذكية و
أصبحت مطابخ السحابة الخاصة بالمنظمة المهيكلة
نموذج الأعمال التالي
لعلامات المطاعم التي تستمر
في الازدهار في عصر الإنترنت
alani jakas cnn
[موسيقى]